[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend in allen vor ein paar
stunden haben sich die mächtigen der
westlichen welt zusammen geschaltet eine
kurzfristig vereinbarte krisenkonferenz
der us-präsident der französische die eu
und nato chefs der bundeskanzler und
weitere ein thema die lage im ukraine
konflikt man muss kein militär experte
sein um zu ahnen da spitzt sich etwas
bedrohlich zu die warnungen werden jetzt
dringlicher das ist der us
sicherheitsberater james sullivan vor
etwas mehr als einer stunde
alle amerikaner sollten die ukraine
verlassen in den nächsten 24 bis 48
stunden
laut der britischen zeitung the guardian
hat joe biden seinen westlichen
verbündeten gesagt er glaube wladimir
putin sei bereits dazu entschlossen in
die ukraine einzumarschieren dieser
meldung widerspricht der
us-sicherheitsberater ob putin die
entscheidung für einen marschbefehl
getroffen habe wisse er nicht klar ist
aber beim blick auf die karte mit den
russischen militär bewegungen die
ukraine von drei seiten aus unter druck
zu setzen oder anzugreifen die option
zumindest hätte sich russland
mittlerweile geschaffen wir beginnen
unsere berichterstattung heute abend mit
dem beitrag von andreas künast
zu militärübungen vor die krim befohlen
einen monat lang war die potro morgen
auf unterwegs vom atlantik über das
mittelmeer ins schwarze meer heute
erreicht das landungsschiff das manöver
gebiet vor der küste der krim zusammen
mit fünf weiteren russischen
kriegsschiffen die krim ist ukraine
steht auf dem blauen großplakat vor der
russischen botschaft in kiew ein riesen
denkzettel aber sonst alles ruhig dass
die sicherheit des botschaftsgebäudes
gefährdet sei ist der jüngste vorwurf
aus russland moskau erwägt alle
diplomaten zu evakuieren um sie vor
provokationen der ukrainischen regierung
zu schützen die stimmung wird schlechter
in kiew immer mehr staaten rufen ihre
bürger zur ausreise auf darunter japan
die niederlande kanada
die usa
amerikaner sollten gehen jetzt wir haben
es mit einer der größten armeen der welt
zu tun die dinge könnten schnell außer
kontrolle geraten
angesichts der täglich neuen hinweise
auch aus sozialen medien auf eine
schnell weiter wachsende russische
truppenstärke hatten sich die augen der
halben welt gestern auf diese villa am
tegeler see in berlin gerichtet bei dem
versuch die lage in der ost ukraine zu
entschärfen haben zwei spitzendiplomaten
des kanzleramtes und des elysée-palasts
putins persönlichen berater dimitri
kosak und selen cigs rechte hand andrea
back in einen raum bekommen es ist das
zweite treffen im sogenannten normandie
format seit beginn des russischen aufmaß
es endet spät in der nacht ist bringt
keinen fortschritt
leider leider sind die verhandlungen
ohne greifbare ergebnisse zu ende
gegangen
heute konnten wir uns auf kein
gemeinsames dokument einigen obwohl wir
neun stunden miteinander diskutiert
haben
obwohl vor allem russland schwere
vorwürfe gegen die ukraine erhebt dass
das treffen überhaupt zustande kam wird
als zeichen des guten willens gesehen
an die minister vereinbarungen
festhalten dass wir den faden nicht
abreißen lassen und dass man sich im
märz erneut treffen wird spektakulär die
zahl der teilnehmer die us präsident
biden am abend zusammen schalten lässt
die staatschefs von frankreich polen
rumänien die regierungschefs von
deutschland kanada italien
großbritannien sowie die chefs der nato
und der eu die usa warnen ihre freunde
jetzt könnte eine invasion jederzeit
beginnen sollte putin sie anordnen die
bilder aus russland alarmieren den
westen mehr denn je wird versucht eine
diplomatische lösung zu finden
dann bringen wir unsere
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
in berlin kiew moskau und washington mit
dazu und beginnen mit der claudia bates
washington was bringt denn die us
regierung jetzt dazu heute abend alarm
zu schlagen welche neuen erkenntnisse
hat joe biden
die us regierung sagt sie sei zum
schluss gekommen dass russland seine
truppen jetzt weit genug um die ukraine
herum aufgebaut habe um eine klare
möglichkeit zu schaffen zu einem großen
angriff auf die ukraine und zwar
jederzeit auch möglicherweise schon
während der olympischen spiele noch es
wurde sogar ein szenario genannt eine
wahrscheinlichkeit bestünde dass es
losging mit einem luftangriff und dann
mit bodentruppen ein schneller vorstoss
aus kiew erfolgen könnte der
sicherheitsberater jack sullivan sagte
die sorge sei jetzt einfach so groß dass
man deswegen damit an die öffentlichkeit
gehen würde gleichzeitig gab er wieder
keine belege für neue erkenntnisse für
neue
geheimdiensterkenntnisse die
us-regierung hat in dieser ganzen sache
ja auffallend offensiv kommuniziert eine
kommunikationsstrategie die auch
eingesetzt werden kann gleichsam als
waffe wellmann putin damit nach eigenen
angaben davon abhalten will die so
beschriebenen szenarien daneben auch
eintreten zu lassen man sei auf alles
vorbereitet die us regierung hat gerade
noch mitgeteilt dass 3000 weitere
soldaten nach polen geschickt werden in
den nächsten tagen also auch das quasi
eine theoretische möglichkeit man sagt
so häufig eine invasion könnte
unmittelbar bevorstehen
dass putin sie gerade deshalb dann nicht
anordnet axel sturm in moskau wie sind
denn die reaktionen auf diese signale
aus washington heute bei ihnen in moskau
ja es gab jetzt im laufe des abends noch
keine direkte reaktion auf die
spitzengespräche am nachmittag und am am
frühen abend und es gibt auch keine
zeichen der entspannung das muss man
ganz klar sagen also man hat das erst
gestern wieder gesehen gestern war ja
die britische außenministerin list
straße in moskau zu besuch bei ihrem
russischen amtskollegen sergej lavrov
und das müssen ganz ganz schwierige
gespräche gewesen sein das war auf eine
kalte krieg rhetorik vor und lauf
beschrieb das gespräch als ein gespräch
zwischen einem tauben und einem stummen
und wies noch einmal darauf hin dass
überhaupt kein verständnis dafür
bestehen dass nach der russischen sicht
der westen sozusagen garantien von
russland einfordere in einer zeit in der
russland nach garantien frage man aber
im besten überhaupt nicht bereit sei auf
russland zu gehen also ganz schwierige
situationen auch ben wallace war heute
hier der britische verteidigungsminister
bei seinem amtskollegen schoigu sagte
danach die beziehung zwischen russland
und großbritannien seien in etwa bei
null mit tendenz sinkend also ins
negative alles keine guten zeichen und
ich glaube inzwischen nach den wochen
der lang und vielen gesprächen nach den
schriftwechseln auf allerhöchstem niveau
und mit spitzenpolitikern aus der ganzen
welt muss die frage legitim sein ist
russland tatsächlich an ernsthafter
diplomatie interessiert oder hat man im
kreml ganz andere pläne und dann haben
wir heute aus dem weißen haus von
sicherheitsberater auch gehört ein
schneller angriff auf kiew sei eine
mögliche aktion von russland wie viel
besorgnis führt man denn in kiew lothar
becker
hier auf dem main damen hinter mir in
kiew spürt man eigentlich gar keine
akute kriegsangst im gegenteil gerade
unter jungen menschen würde ich sagen
ist das hier ein
netter fast schon und was muss ich
wirklich so sagen auch laut starker
freitagabend ganz anders ist die lage
ganz sicher in chaco der zweitgrößten
stadt hier in der ukraine da hat
präsident zielinski heute auch nur
angedeutet sie könnte ein mögliches ziel
sein im falle eines schlags russen aber
das hat in charkow selber direkt für
unmut gesorgt denn die menschen dann
gesagt nein charkow ist ukraine und so
merkt man doch dass die lage war
angespannt bleibt auch natürlich
politisch spätestens seit heute das
ultimatum an russland gestellt wurde die
ukraine verlangt anhand der wiener
dokumente der sct das eben klar
dargelegt wird welche
militärmacht denn da auf der anderen
seite der grenzen steht und fordert von
russland jetzt innerhalb von 48 stunden
klar zu sagen was denn es sich mit
diesen übungen auf sich hat diesen
sogenannten übungen ja welche militär
machte da eben geht sollte das in 48
stunden nicht beantwortet werden dann
gibt es direkte gespräche und dann muss
russland offenlegen was das wort und
dann bringt mit theo koll mit dazu in
berlin theo der bundeskanzler wenn ja
nächste woche nach kiew und nach moskau
fliegen macht diese reise noch sinn oder
macht sie erst jetzt vielleicht erst
richtig sind na ja jetzt erst recht muss
man sagen angesichts all dessen was auf
dem spiel steht lohnt sich glaube ich
jeder reise allerdings hat washington ja
heute abend wir haben es gehörte
landsleute aufgefordert binnen 24 bis 48
stunden die ukraine zu verlassen wenn
das also ein reales zeitmaß für eine
mögliche russische invasion wäre dann
allerdings gehen wir die reise zu spät
das kanzleramt ist aber offen sich
entspannter in der einschätzung denn aus
berlin gibt es noch keine ukraine
evakuierungs aufforderung für dort
lebende deutsche beiden hat
offensichtlich anders als am abend von
einigen berichtet wird in der video
schalte gesagt man wisse nicht ob eine
invasions entscheidung gefallen sei es
stünde noch ein wichtiges treffen bei
putin aus so jedenfalls beiden für
berlin bleibt deeskalation das gebot der
stunde und kanzler scholz dürfte dabei
in moskau glaubwürdigkeit reklamieren
denn er hat gerade erst wieder die
haubitzen lieferungen die ukraine
verhindert und er weigert sich ja weiter
beharrlich bei den sanktionen nord
stream 2 in den mund zu nehmen ob all
das bei putin dann das richtige
reisegepäck ist das wird sich dann
vielleicht am dienstag erweisen und
morgen gibt es auch nochmal
telefondiplomatie putin mag
und putin beiden auch dass zwei wichtige
gespräche ganz herzlichen dank an die
kolleginnen und kollegen in kiew in
moskau washington und natürlich auch in
bern und wir machen jetzt erstmal
nachrichten mit cola
aus ministerin baerbock hat auf ihre
nahost-reise jordanien besucht und sich
für eine ausweitung der internationalen
flüchtlingshilfe dort ausgesprochen eine
stärkere deutsche unterstützung wolle
sie prüfen außerdem vereinbarte baerbock
mit ihrem amtskollegen alpha die
gemeinsam den friedensprozess von
palästinensern und israelis
voranzutreiben zum abschluss ihrer
antritts besucher im nahen osten wird
die ministerin morgen in ägypten
erwartet
spd-chef ascon hat konsequenzen aus dem
urteil des landgerichts osnabrück zur
durchsuchung der ministerien für justiz
und finanzen kurz vor der bundestagswahl
im letzten jahr gefordert die razzien
seien also unzulässig gewesen hätten dem
ansehen der damals spd-geführten
ministerien geschadet und seien ein
indiskutabler eingriff in den wahlkampf
gewesen bei den damaligen ermittlungen
ging es um den verdacht der
unzureichenden geldwäschebekämpfung beim
zoll
die bundesregierung streicht von sonntag
an mehrere länder von der liste der
korona hochrisiko gebiete darunter malta
kanada und einige karibikstaaten derzeit
sind weltweit etwa drei viertel aller
rund 200 länder als hoch risikogebiet
eingestuft die zahl in deutschland
soweit sie vorliegen steigen zwar weiter
aber nicht mehr so schnell dass rk ii
registrierte 240.000 172 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden acht
1666 weniger als vor einer woche
226 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incident steigt leicht auf
1.472
in frankreich sind mehrere tausend
autofahrer nach paris unterwegs um nach
kanadischem vorbild gegen die korona
maßnahmen zu protestieren
offiziell ist die aktion verboten
allerdings ist die polizei schon mit
tausenden beamten im einsatz um die
fahrer aufzuhalten die grenzblockade
zwischen kanada und den usa aus protest
gegen korona vorschriften dauert nun
seit vier tagen an in autofabriken bei
der länder musste deswegen die
produktion zeitweise gestoppt werden
was ist eigentlich das ziel unserer
corona strategie in deutschland diese
frage steht mehr denn je im raum weil
von ihr auch abhängt bis wann all die
regeln und maßnahmen noch gelten sollten
bzw
gelten können zu dieser frage gibt es
viele diskussionen auch viel konfusion
mittlerweile aber keine klare antwort
möglichst alle infektionen vermeiden war
mal ein ziel überlastung der
intensivstationen vermeiden war mal ein
ziel und jetzt der bundeskanzler stellt
heute im bundesrat öffnungs schritte in
aussicht der bundesgesundheitsminister
wahrend stützt sich dabei auf
berechnungen die sein eigenes
ministerium nicht wirklich erklären kann
und muss sich jetzt von kritikern
anhören vor allem angst zu verbreiten
britta spiekermann berichtet
kanzler scholz an einem besonderen ort
also jackett an vor seiner antrittsrede
im bundesrat gleichklang gab es hier
selten während der pandemie eher
eigenwillige soli nun also alle augen
auf scholz' gerichtet denn das terrain
vorbereitet für die
ministerpräsidentinnen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
kommenden mittwoch die
wissenschaftlichen prognosen zeigen uns
dass der höhepunkt der welle in sicht
ist das erlaubt uns beim bund länder
treffen nächste woche einen ersten
öffnung schritt und dann weitere für das
frühjahr in den blick zu nehmen welche
schritte aber sind das scholz will das
heft in die hand nehmen und bleibt doch
waage die lage ist inzwischen durchaus
verfahren nach und nach verabschieden
sich die länder von der zweig regel im
einzelhandel und bei der einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht gibt politisches
taktieren den takt vor alle sind sich
einig alle länder dass wir große fragen
noch zu klären haben bis das praktikabel
umgesetzt werden kann das eint uns und
uns eint auch dass wir natürlich
bundesrecht umsetzen werden diese
einigkeit gibt es allerdings nicht
ministerpräsident söder hatte erhebliche
ruhe um die teil impfpflicht ausgelöst
aussetzen hatte er gedroht kein vollzug
ein vom bundestag verabschiedetes gesetz
da war es ja ein herzenswunsch von herrn
söder von herrn hans aus dem saarland
das einzuführen das hat die ampel dann
vorgeschlagen die union hat mitgestimmt
im deutschen bundestag im bundesrat und
hat jetzt wochenlang sich vorzubereiten
auch diese bundesländer dann ist es
schon merkwürdig dass man sagt hoops
jetzt ist ja da wir wissen gar nicht wie
wir sie umsetzen sollen minister
lauterbach ist genervt nicht nur vom
widerstand aus bayern auch bei den
lockerungsübungen gehört weiterhin zum
team vorsicht aus der cdu hört man
lauterbach sein angst minister ob ich
angst minister solle nicht als nicht
maßgeblich ich muss mit den fakten
arbeiten jeden tag sterben mit
schwankungen zwischen
150 und 200 menschen pro tag ich finde
es schade dass wir uns daran fast schon
gewöhnt haben und daher sehe ich einfach
nicht ins spiel raum für schneller
lockerungen ich sehe aber dass wir alle
lockerungs perspektive benötigen während
viele länder den ausweg suchen aus den
corona maßnahmen zeichnet lauterbach
düstere bilder so auch im zdf heute
journal vor ein paar tagen hat er davor
warnt nach dem vorbild israels zu öffnen
ich habe mal ausgerechnet wie viele
menschen derzeit also mit der strategie
israels sterben würden wenn wir ähnlich
vorgehen würden und dann kommt man auf
eine also quote von vielleicht 400 500
menschen in deutschland sterben würden
wenn wir also diese öffnungen zu machen
würden lauterbach der wissenschaftler im
amt der selbst mal ausgerechnet hat eine
unsichere prognose in zeiten der
ungenauigkeiten genau falsch sind es
sind die tage der irrungen und wirrungen
und da wäre ja auch noch die allgemeine
impfpflicht eigentlich sollte sie schon
nächste woche im bundestag diskutiert
werden dahinter steht inzwischen ein
großes fragezeichen
sicher ist heute nur am kommenden
mittwoch wird wieder beraten im
kanzleramt wird es einen coruna fahrplan
für die zukunft geben vieles steht in
den sternen
deutschlands höchstes gericht hat eine
klagewelle zu managen und es muss
schnell gehen 74 verfassungsbeschwerden
von etwa 300 klägerin und klägern die in
der pflege arbeiten und sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen dazu medizinische
einrichtungen die auch ungeimpfte
beschäftigen wollen sie alle wehren sich
gegen die geplante impfpflicht für
gesundheits und pflegeberufe mit ihrem
eilantrag beim bundesverfassungsgericht
sind sie heute gescheitert das gesetz
kann erst mal kommen welche juristischen
fragen sich daraus ergeben dazu sprechen
wir gleich erst steffen moritz und die
situation vor ort in einem pflegeheim in
sachsen
für männlich streit sich war es die
schlimmste zeit in ihrem berufsleben als
anfang letzten jahres in ihrem
pflegeheim in kürzester zeit 20 bewohner
an corona starben für sie ist klar jeder
mitarbeiter muss sich impfen lassen
gerade die die jetzt sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen besonders in der pflege
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen sind für
mich egoisten weil sie in dem moment ja
nur an sich denken und nicht an die
bewohner ihre kollegin nicole sieht das
aber anders also ich habe wirklich angst
vor irgend welchen nebenwirkungen und ja
ich möchte das einfach akzeptiert wurde
ich schütze mich ich will gehen jeden
tag zum testen
natürlich suchen dafür dass ich in ihm
arbeiten auf natürlich
ich kann ja alles passieren das macht
doch mit allem was im kopf weil wie
gesagt ich liebe den beruf
mandy und nicole arbeiten trotzdem gut
miteinander und schätzen sich aber eine
ganze zeit gab es wegen der impfpflicht
heftige diskussionen im team die station
chefin mirella 1000 stark beschäftigten
werden von ihren 35 mitarbeitern waren
bis vor kurzem 8 ungeimpft inzwischen
sind es noch drei
eskalieren wo man wirklich eingreifen
musste und schlichten musste und nach
möglichkeit im dienstplan das dann so
regeln dass die nicht zusammen
eingeteilt sind aber
deutlich ruhe eingekehrt und kollegen
kommt wieder gerne auf arbeit
geschäftsführer markus beyer frustriert
vor allem dass er von der politik
keinerlei antworten auf wichtige fragen
bekommt das ist natürlich schwierig für
uns als arbeitgeber auch sofern wir ja
auch von der politik nicht wirklich eine
klare aussage eine klare antwort
erhalten wie wir unseren verhalten
sollen ab dem 15 es gibt zwar die
möglichkeit der gesundheitsämter dies
signalisiert haben sie möchten jetzt im
moment kein betretungsverbot aussprechen
so fern da die sachlage auch noch nicht
klar ist allerdings ist es für uns
natürlich schwierig weil wir haben ja
auch noch andere gesetze nämlich das
arbeitsrecht was uns vorgibt wie wir den
arbeitsschutz gewährleisten müssen bei
uns in der unternehmen und der ganz
andere frage die sich mir noch stellt
persönlich ist die haftung die
haftungsfrage was passiert wenn sich
jemand infiziert man habe das gefühl die
gesellschaftlichen probleme werden
gerade allein auf den pflegebereich
verlagert und das schade dem ansehen des
pflegeberufes enorm
gerade so die pflege die es in den
letzten jahren haben wir immer gehofft
es wird sich mal besseres verdiene es
wurde für uns geklatscht das erste ja
noch und heute da fand es gar nichts mit
zu spielen also wir fühlen uns nach wie
vor allein gelassen man sieht uns nicht
man hört uns nicht so es ist
frustrierend
nicoles watt denkt inzwischen darüber
nach sich vielleicht doch mit dem tod
impfstoff impfen zu lassen und der
sächsische ministerpräsident hat sich
übrigens gerade dafür ausgesprochen die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht um
einige monate zu verschieben die
bedenken der mitarbeiter müssten ernst
genommen werden
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt
selbst erst mal diverse fachleute
befragt welchen schutz genau impfungen
bieten wie die übertragbarkeit trotz
impfung aussieht und dann seine
entscheidung getroffen die geplante
impfpflicht für pflege und
gesundheitsberufe kann erst mal kommen
sarah tacke aus unserer rechts redaktion
und sarah das ist jetzt eine
entscheidung ist denn schon absehbar ob
das gericht das auch generell so sehen
wird ich halte es für sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das gericht auch in
der hauptsache also eine endgültige
entscheidung an der einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht festhält und sagt
dies mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar denn
die kritikpunkte heute waren vor allem
formaler natur und da kann der
gesetzgeber schnell und einfach
nachbessern das sollte er auch aber dann
ist es sicherlich nicht das bund das
gericht dass sich der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht in den weg stellt
jetzt ist es ja faktisch auch so dass
auch geimpfte andere infizieren können
ist denn das bei den höchsten
richterinnen und richtern in die
abwägung mit eingeflossen überhaupt
nicht das ist doch erstaunlich der
beschluss ist zwar sehr schlank seiten
an der zahl aber die verfassungsrichter
machen eine simple rechnung auf sie
sagen jeder der geimpft ist kann der
geringere wahrscheinlichkeit zu
infizieren sich selber zu infizieren und
je mehr medizinisches personal sich
nicht infiziert desto weniger oft wird
das virus auch ins krankenhaus getragen
und trifft die dort schwachsinn das
heißt sie sagen es ist sehr viel
wahrscheinlichkeit dass menschen die
älter sind sich infizieren und sterben
als die folge der schaden wie die
betroffenen fürchten nämlich dass sie
durch die impfung folgeschäden erleiden
da sagen die verfassungsrichter
datenexperten uns gesagt das ist sehr
sehr selten deswegen kern der
entscheidung ist dass die impfpflicht
und die impfung zentrales um die
schwachen zu schützen und dahinter muss
der wille anderer menschen umgehe impfte
bleiben und gerade vom medizinischen
personal zurücktreten das gesetz kann
jetzt also vorerst umgesetzt werden das
alte ja auch so ein bisschen 15 dritter
ist bereits der stichtag jetzt ist es
aber so dass bayerns ministerpräsident
ja bereits angekündigt hat er werde das
erstmal nicht umsetzen in seinem
bundesland da reibt man sich ja so ein
bisschen die augen kann das einfach so
sagen der ministerpräsident von bayern
ein gesetz dass er selbst im bundesrat
mitbeschlossen hat das geht gar nicht da
gibt es auch gar kein vertun und auch
kein ermessen denn dieses gesetz ist
durch den bundestag gegangen ist es im
bundesrat einstimmig auch bayern habe
ich dagegen gestimmt verabschiedet
worden und es gilt jetzt und in einem
gesetz steht auch muss nicht kann nicht
soll sondern muss da gibt es überhaupt
keinen ermessensspielraum und wenn ein
bundesland nun sich dagegen stellt dann
stellte sich auch gegen den rechtsstaat
aber der rechtsstaat ist nicht machtlos
er kann zum einen kann der bund vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen und das
land verklagen und es kann auch den
sogenannten bundes zwang anwenden das
heißt es kann ein bundes kommissar in
das land schicken und durchgreifend es
noch nie gegeben hat es noch nie gegeben
rechtlich aber möglich ok sarah tacke
ganz herzlich lage heute abend wieder
für diese interessanten juristischen
erläuterungen und zur allgemeinen
impfpflicht die ja auch noch schwer in
der diskussion ist die allgemeine
impfpflicht also für alle haben cdu und
csu im bundestag jetzt einen eigenen
vorschlag vorgelegt fragen dazu von
nazan götte mehr an den
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der
union nachher im heute-journal update
jetzt aber erstmal da gehe ich jetzt ein
bisschen rüber nachrichten noch mal wird
die ruderer trotz des weltweiten chip
mangels hat der autobauer mercedes benz
im vergangenen jahr einen
milliardengewinn erzielt und damit
deutlich mehr als erwartet dabei hat der
konzern weniger autos ausgeliefert als
im vorjahr frank bethmann mercedes
änderte die produktionsstrategie
offenbar mit erfolg ja für einen moment
sieht es jetzt ganz gut aus mercedes hat
gewissermaßen die not zu einer neuen
unternehmensausrichtung genutzt man hat
gesagt wenn wir zu wenig halbleiter
haben gegenwärtig alle autos zu bauen
dann produzieren wir doch erst mal die
wagen an denen wir eine hohe marge haben
und so wurden s-klasse maybach und
andere hochwertige fahrzeuge vorrangig
gefertigt zudem hielt man am strammen
sparkurs fest insgesamt eine strategie
die sich auszahlte obwohl die
auslieferung von mercedes im vorjahr um
5 prozent schrumpften also weniger autos
verkauft wurden verdiente der konzern
mehr geld denn je verdoppelte seinen
bereinigten betriebsgewinn auf 14
milliarden euro doch beim stuttgarter
autobauer der seit kurzem unter mercedes
benz groupie an der börse firmiert ahnt
man bereits nach dem deutlichen
gewinnplus droht gegenwind die
rohstoffpreise galoppieren davon und
treiben die kosten ohne einen höheren
autoabsatz im laufenden jahr wird sich
ein solches ergebnis wohl nicht
wiederholen lassen frank bethmann vielen
dank in der fußball-bundesliga waren in
leipzig heute abend 15.000 zuschauer für
das spiel gegen den fc köln zugelassen
es endete gerade eben mit einem 3 1-sieg
für leipzig
nach dem erneuten ausbruch des größten
aktiven vulkans in europa dem ätna auf
sizilien steigt immer noch asche aus dem
krater die italienischen behörden geben
die höhe der rauchsäule mit rund 8000
metern an gestern abend hatte der ätna
lavafontänen gespuckt drei ströme
glühenden gesteins flossen hunderte
meter den berg hinab im vergangenen jahr
war direkt nach mehrfach ausgebrochen
und mit diesen eindrucksvollen bildern
aus dem schönen sizilien verabschieden
wir beide uns nah sein möchte mir meldet
sich also nur 30 mit unserem
heute-journal update im zdf programm
gleich das politbarometer und danach die
heute show quiz und ein gutes wochenende
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer im kräfteverhältnis der
parteien ist so einiges in bewegung
die union kommt aus ihrem langen
umfrage-tief heraus und legt weiter zu
wohl auch weil die führungsfrage in der
cdu geklärt ist der neue parteichef
friedrich merz kann offenbar punkten
trotz verlusten der grünen und der fdp
hätte die ampel regierung aber weiter
eine mehrheit wenn am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die spd auf 25
prozent plus 1 die cdu csu lege jetzt
gleich auf 25 prozent plus 2
grüne 16 prozent -2 fdp 9 -1 afd 11 plus
1 die linke käme auf 6 prozent minus
eins die
spd kann sich nach den verlusten im
januar wieder stabilisieren rund zwei
monate ist bundeskanzler scholz jetzt im
amt und steht bereits in der kritik zu
wenig führungsstärke zu zeigen wie sehen
das die deutschen
weiterhin meint die mehrheit von 56
prozent stolz macht seine arbeit gut
aber die zustimmung sinkt 34 prozent
finden jetzt dass er einen schlechten
job macht zwei drittel der befragten
sind der meinung er zeige er keine
führung merkel
als kanzlerin merkel erfreut sich
dagegen immer noch großer beliebtheit
sie wird von den befragten weiter zu den
wichtigsten köpfen gezählt unsere top
ten der wichtigsten politikerinnen und
politiker nach sympathie und leistung
auf der skala von plus fünf bis minus
fünf
schlusslicht ist sahra wagenknecht minus
0,1 unverändert davor markus söder 0,2
etwas schlechter auf rang acht friedrich
merz 0,3 besser vor ihm annalena
baerbock auch 0,3 etwas schlechter auf
platz 6 christian lindner 0,9 verbessert
robert habeck 1,0 mit leichten verlusten
vor ihm cem özdemir 1,1 unverändert auf
rang 3 karl lauterbach 1,3 olaf scholz
ebenfalls 1,3 beide etwas schlechter
auch ohne amt an der spitze angela
merkel 2,5 etwas besser
schauen wir auf die korona lage die zahl
der deutschen die sich um die eigene
gesundheit sorgen macht ist weiter
gesunken auf das niveau vor der
mikrowelle entsprechend sind viele für
lockerungen der korona schutzmaßnahmen
in der nächsten zeit
23 prozent der befragten wünschen sich
jetzt schon weitere lockerungen 38
prozent sind für lockerungen in zwei bis
drei wochen ebenso viele wollen noch
länger damit warten
eine allgemeine impfpflicht gegen korona
hält die mehrheit für richtig auch wenn
die zustimmung etwas rückläufig ist
drei von vier befragten bezweifeln
allerdings dass sie auch wirklich kommt
deutlich mehr als vor zwei wochen für
beschäftigte im gesundheitsbereich und
in der pflege ist die impfpflicht
bereits beschlossen steht aber in der
kritik
eine aussetzung der impfpflicht im
gesundheitsbereich stimmen nur 34
prozent der befragten zu die mehrheit
von 63 prozent ist dagegen das sehen die
anhänger aller parteien mehrheitlich so
außer die der afd
die anhänger der fdp sind da geteilter
meinung
mit hochdruck wurde diese woche
verhandelt um den ukraine konflikt zu
entschärfen
die gefahren einschätzung der deutschen
hat sich inzwischen verändert mit einem
einmarsch russischer truppen in der
ukraine rechnen mittlerweile weniger
befragte als noch ende januar und was
erwartet die bevölkerung von der
bundesregierung
deutschland sollte den wirtschaftlichen
druck auf russland erhöhen findet jeder
zweite 43 prozent sehen das nicht so
waffen an die ukraine zu liefern das
vorhin nur 20 prozent eine deutliche
mehrheit von 75 prozent ist dagegen
am sonntag wird ein neuer
bundespräsident gewählt und
wahrscheinlich wird der alte auch der
neue sein frank walter steinmeier sein
ansehen in der bevölkerung ist groß
85 prozent der deutschen finden dass
frank walter steinmeier seine sache in
der ersten amtszeit gut gemacht hat zehn
prozent sagen er hat es schlecht gemacht
die zustimmung ist bei den anhängern
aller parteien sehr hoch außer bei der
afd
von der historischen wahl des
bundespräsidenten unter corona
bedingungen berichten wir am sonntag
live in einem zdf spezial ab 11 uhr 50
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politkrimi
politbarometer punkt zdf.de vielen dank
für ihr interesse das nächste
politbarometer gibt es dann in zwei
wochen schon am donnerstag den 24
februar
nach dem wetter geht's hier weiter mit
der heute-show ihm noch einen
entspannten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend strengem dauerfrost gibt es
morgen nur hier im nördlichen
skandinavien mit minus 15 grad sonst
liegen die höchsttemperaturen europaweit
meist so bei etwa null bis zehn grad
milder ist es am mittelmeer 20 grad gibt
es an der algarve 20 grad bieten auch
die kanarischen inseln aber temperaturen
über zehn grad wie kommen jetzt auch zu
uns und das liegt daran dass dieses hoch
ingo weiter nach osten zieht und damit
dreht die strömung auf südwest und sie
sehen wie diese grüne zunge auch zu uns
nach deutschland reicht jetzt in der
nacht wird erst mal kalt die
temperaturen sinken am alpenrand bis
minus 11 grad minus 1 grad sind es an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee machen
sie sich noch auf letzte schneeschauer
gefasst zwischen dem thüringer wald und
dem bayerischen wald da kann es also
auch noch mal glatt seien auf den
straßen morgen dann aber strahlt die
sonne und es gibt meist nur ganz
harmlose wolken höchstens in
norddeutschland sind sie mal etwas
dichter der wind kommt aus südlichen
richtungen und die temperaturen liegen
morgens zwischen 2 grad im osten und
maximal 9 grad zum beispiel am rhein
wahrscheinlich wird's inkasso am
mildesten am sonntag nimmt an der
südwestwind zu und so steigen die
temperaturen am oberrhein bis 14 grad
auch am sonntag gibt es meist nur
harmlose wolken am montag dann aber wird
es dann von westen deutlich regnerischer
es wird auch sehr viel wendiger und bis
zur wochenmitte merklich kälter schönes
wochenende